Will we have a Republic or populism?
In politics,
form is substance,
reason why the only
Attention from officials
can account for attachment to principles
or,
on the contrary,
of populism and budding authoritarianism.
Retirement
the fences that prevented the passage
in front of the presidential house
and next to the National Palace,
was received by the population
as a sincere change of attitude.
Then,
the use of a Bic pen
for the signing of a governmental agreement
revoking one of the past administration,
was praised by Arevalo's supporters.
The walk
in the street of a group of seeded deputies
to paradise,
filmed and widely distributed on social networks
by several accounts,
that those of that party would have called
such as New centers,
was also sold as an act of simplicity.
In the face of these messages,
it should be recalled that the apparent or genuine
simplicity is no guarantee of anything in itself.
For example,
former Mexican President Carlos Salinas de Gortari,
in public always used a simple
quartz watch and plastic strap,
no longer in purely symbolic matters,
but substantial.
The presidential elections of the executive and legislative branches
made speeches and made statements
that if they show the way of thinking and intentions
of whom they spoke.
These irregularities did not go unnoticed.
President Arevalo gave an interview
to CNN in which he referred to the invitation made to him by
to the Attorney General,
consolation truncheons,
to report on aspects of
of its management
while there is still no call for assistance.
What is worrying are the president's intentions.
Questioned about the situation of somes
and self-exiled,
the Chairman called for case review
and to create the conditions
for their return to the country in the case of
that we
We regain control over the Public Prosecutor's Office.
The MP is independent and autonomous
and the superitation of a foreign official
or to the state institution or agency
is precisely what Arevalo and Seed said.
that occurred during the Yamategui government.
That now Arevalo has said
who will regain control of the MP
it was not a lapse,
but rather a strict statement of intent
in collision with principles.
For his part,
Congressman
Samuel Perez read a short speech
on the court's decision
of constitutionality,
where he said that the court decided to enter
in a direct pulse against aging,
but above all against the will of the people.
It is understandable that they oppose the CC's decision.
and that, by exercising
the of irresponsibility in their opinions,
as allowed to deputies by article
161 of the Constitution,
to express itself as such with respect to the,
but something very painful,
i.e.,
the CC makes a pulse with or solves
contrary to the will of the people
decisions of a judge,
magistrate or tribunal,
whatever it is,
They cannot be superjected to the popular will,
but exclusively to the Constitution and the laws.
Congressman Pérez's is a populist expression and,
again,
contrary to principles.
Although it is very early
to affirm the course it will take to
the Arevalo government and its seed party,
the expressions of the presidents of two
state agencies,
in authoritarian and populist terms,
are signs of what may be to come.
Under no circumstances should it be permitted to
that the executive takes
control over the Public Prosecutor's Office,
and that the decisions of the courts are submitted to
a plebiscite.
We invite you to subscribe to our newsletters
in Republic,
point g t diagonal newsleaders.
During the week
will receive political and business analysis.
I don't understand which Republic
publishes its editorials every Thursday